et 150000 réactions sur antoine
griezmann
alors on va revoir s'est passé hier sur
twitter antoine griezmann a posté une
photo de lui déguisant basketteur noir
des années 80 et cette photo a déclenché
une polémique sur twitter car les
internautes ont jugé la blague de très
mauvais goût et antoine griezmann après
a réagi l'amicale mots ses amis je suis
fan des harlem globetrotters et de cette
belle époque c'est un hommage
il a retweeté dernier est obligé de se
justifier et là il avait continué d'art
je reconnais que c'est maladroit de ma
part si j'ai blessé certains je m'en
excuse
alors regardez la photo d'antoine
griezmann voilà qui est voilà c'est ça
donc voilà je m'impose la blackface
aient fait polémique
est ce que ça vous a dérangé ici pour
kissima si ça me dérange qu'on
l'emmerdent pour ça donc si vous la
faute aux usa déranger mais pas du tout
j'ai fait mille fois j'adore ça et ouais
bah tout va bien mais non mais ce qui me
dérange c'est que c'est que ya une
polémique parce qu'il a fait ça c'est
quoi alors l'action nissan ou
fonctionner je crois que les gens font
un amalgame
imaginez moi me déguisé en michael
jackson et dont il a secret les gens non
mais oui mais c'est aussi la raison des
chocs et déjà comme ça je suis
extrêmement choqué ou non mais je veux
dire pourquoi la retraite nous je veux
dire très calmement blackface aux etats
unis c'est apparu dans les années 1920
et depuis 1964 c'est considéré comme
raciste ni avec les droits civiques
donc je ne dis pas que je ne dis pas que
griezmann est raciste mais ce qu'il a
fait là c'est raciste parce qu'on veut
pas gris mais le cirage noir sur la peau
blanche je suis désolé c'est connoté à
montoir noté quoi pardon irisé il est
régulier harlem globetrotters slovaquie
reste au blond nous tu as déjà eu et a
déjà eu harlem globe trotter blanc toi
jamais réussi c'est considéré comme
raciste aux armées mais on n'est pas aux
états unis alors on va dominer début
évidemment que c'est du racisme à deux
vitesses il ya des quotas pour les noirs
dans les séries en france comme aux
états unis
non ils devraient le divina y arrive
devrait alors on s'entend mais tu aurais
pas drôle mais non
le valais explique j'ai pas perso à
titre totalement personnel a été choqué
par par la photo dans trois d'antoine
griezmann je pense qu'il est très
sincère quand il a parlé dommage c'est
véritablement un hommage à des idoles
qu'il a voulu faire en revanche qu'il le
veuille ou non et qu'on accepte ou non
aujourd'hui ça passe pas michalek grille
mais aujourd'hui en noir santa abandon
pardon pardon pardon c'est pas pareil à
l'année c'est pas mes lunettes cinéma
mrc du black is it ne soit pas michel
mais c'est la période qui veut ça change
tout la maison parce que les chalets il
fait des imitations serre mais
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on va tous en
même temps jean luc baiwir remember me
satisfait aujourd'hui les nuls
aujourd'hui les nuls ou les inconnus il
serait interdit d'antenne rien alors il
s'en inquiète tellement echazar tonnes
on va taxer ses virées pour une vague de
merde on va revenir sur la tronche
non mais ça c'est un débat qu'on connaît
le côté patrick timsit qui arrivait à
coucou qui disait là j'ai perdu cinq
kilos
enfin j'ai pas de 7 kg de couilles
impossible ici impossible car tout ici
il a vraiment changé maintenant ça c'est
pas c'est pas de la blague il a pas fait
une blague les neiges a fait un truc de
photos c'est un malade sur un nuage